Die zweite Bundesliga der Männer, sie bleibt einfach interessant. Der HSV verliert in Paderborn, Lautern und Magdeburg gerade auf Rang 2 und 3. Da kenn ich einige, die würden sagen, ja, nehm ich als Aufsteiger. Und auch unten drin passiert wieder so einiges. Wie gut, dass wieder Ligaturzeit ist und wir jetzt hier gleich darüber sprechen. Aber nicht ich, sondern Eva Lottabohle wird natürlich wieder moderieren. Und dann legen wir heute Schwerpunkte auf Darmstadt 98 mit Matthias Kneifel und auf Hannover 96 mit Max Boxer. Freue mich schon sehr auf die Sendung. Ich werde gleich wieder verschwinden. Warum mache ich dann dieses Intro? Es gibt wichtige Neuigkeiten, die den Rasenfunk betreffen und die muss ich euch an dieser Stelle mitteilen. Und zwar werden wir dazu gezwungen, unsere Kontoverbindung zu verändern. Details dazu werden wir vielleicht mal irgendwann in einem Tribüngespräch erklären. Wichtig für euch zu wissen ist, wir haben einen relativ kurzen Zeitraum, in dem ihr dann euren Dauerauftrag auf das neue Konto umstellen müsst. Noch wissen wir noch nicht die neue E-Bahn, aber wir würden euch bitten, registriert euch doch bitte schon mal als Supporterinnen und Supporter, wenn ihr uns unterstützt oder unterstützen wollt. Denn dann landet ihr auf dem News-Verteiler, den wir dann eben verwenden können, sobald wir alle Infos dazu haben. Ihr werdet nicht zugespämmt, keine Sorge. In der Regel bekommt ihr eine bis zwei E-Mails, geht einfach auf rasenfunk.de und dann im Menü kann man sich als Supporter in registrieren. Und wie gesagt, es passiert nichts anderes, als dass wir einfach eure Mail-Adresse bekommen. Ihr könnt auch anklicken, ob ihr dann nach dem Zufallsprinzip hier erwähnt werden wollt in den Sendungen. Das kennt ihr ja hoffentlich schon. Und vor allem bekommt ihr aber dann von uns Mitte März, wahrscheinlich irgendwann ab dem 19. März von uns eine E-Mail mit allen Infos. Und dann haben wir einen begrenzten Zeitraum, in dem ihr euren Dauerauftrag bitte endet. Und dann wird das hoffentlich für uns finanziell nicht zu schlimm, denn wir hatten ja schon mal einen Bankwechsel und da haben wir festgestellt, trotz aller Bemühungen, da bleiben dann doch einige Supporterbeiträge auf der Strecke. Wir hoffen, diesmal wird es besser. Es wird noch viel mehr Informationen dazu geben. Ich werde das jetzt auch in allen Sendungen ab jetzt sagen. Deswegen beginne ich hier diese Sendung, obwohl ich sie gar nicht moderiere. In diesem Sinne danke für euren Support und jetzt aber viel Spaß mit der Liga Tour. Ich bin raus. Eva, take it away. Und nun im Programm, der Rasenfunk.
Ja, vor allem, also klar ist die eine Sache, wenn man 2-3-0 fielen muss und vielleicht dann hinterher nur unentschieden spielt, aber es ist dann das andere, also noch mal in Worten, 1 zu 4 verliert, nachdem man da 55 Minuten gute Spiele hingelegt hat. Das darf dir halt trotzdem so nicht passieren und ich hab also ich hab Konferenz geguckt und ich stand da immer mal so, was passiert dir denn jetzt? Also ich dachte, da muss ich doch eigentlich aufschwimmen. Vor allem ich fand's halt so, es ist ja das eine, wenn du sowieso aus so einer Negativspirale kommst, es ist also es ist nicht nur ein Klischee, es ist ja einfach so, du kannst es ja immer wieder beobachten. Für Teams, die oben sind, denen fällt es dann einfacher, da vielleicht auch rauszukommen, so ein Spiel zu drehen, da das Selbstbewusstsein rauszuziehen. Und wenn du eher unten drinstehst und vielleicht so ein bisschen die Erfolgserlebnisse wieder ausbleiben, dann ist es halt schwieriger, weil sobald du dann halt ein Gegentor kassierst, dann verselbstständigt sich das Ganze und dann kriegst du halt, dann brichst du halt ein bisschen auseinander, weil du eigentlich sagst, hey, wir haben doch eigentlich bis hier ein gutes Spiel gemacht. Warum kriegen wir den Ertrag nicht daraus? Aber was ich halt, also es ist halt doppelt bitter, weil du eigentlich eben genau diese Serie wieder starten könntest, weil du davor ja zwei Null gegen Schalke gewonnen hast. Und eigentlich dachte ich so, ja, okay, eben auch das, die ersten 55 Minuten, so ey, eigentlich bist du jetzt voll auf der guten Seite und hast eigentlich dieses Momentum. Du bist dann zusammengebrochen. Und ich glaube, also ich hab's eben gesagt, 41 zu 41 Tore, da spiegelt das eigentlich auch ganz gut wider, weil die Offensive, die liegt bei Darmstadt ganz klar über dem Liga-Durchschnitt. Also ich hab's mal ausgerechnet, die liegt immer so 36,6, wo halt zum Beispiel Hannover deutlich drunter ist. Aber die Defensive, die ist halt unterm Durchschnitt eben gleichzeitig, logischerweise auch bei der gleichen Langzeit von Toren. Und da ist halt eben die XG, also die man geschossen hat, die passen eigentlich. Also ich glaube, da liegt ein Tor dazwischen im Endeffekt. Das ist nicht so der große Unterschied. Das liegt schon relativ bei... Also da ist man eigentlich auf seinem Soll, sag ich mal. Da gibt es jetzt keine großen Ausreißer nach oben oder nach unten. Gleicht sich natürlich in so einer Saison auch irgendwann mal aus. Aber gleichzeitig hat man eigentlich acht Tore ungefähr zu viel kassiert.
Ja, das ist wirklich ein springender Punkt.
Und das sind Unterschiede, ne?
Also es gab erst zwei zu null Spiele diese Saison. Einmal zu Hause gegen Münster und einmal jetzt gegen Schalke eben. Und das bedeutet, man hat in 22 Spielen das nicht verstanden, sein Tor ausreichend abzusichern. Und das wirkt jetzt eigentlich auch, wenn man die Spiele verfolgt, nicht irgendwie wie ein Hühnerhaufen da hinten. Das wirkt schon relativ stabil. Vukotic hat sich als Neuzugang nahtlos eingefügt in das Team und ist für mich auch noch eher der Abwehrchef in der Viererkette als jetzt Clemens Riegel, der als Kapitän auch erst 21 ist, aber auch jetzt gegen Magdeburg mutmaßlich gefehlt hat in diesem Abwehrverbund. Aber dennoch, wir schaffens einfach nicht oder die Lilien schaffens einfach nicht die Null zu halten. Und das ist natürlich schon schwer, wenn du nicht davon ausgehen kannst, ein Tor reicht dir um Sieg zu erringen, sondern du musst eigentlich schon mehr draufsatteln, dann wirds schwer. Und beispielhaft sind für mich zwei Gegentore der jüngsten Vergangenheit, nämlich dieses 0 zu 1 in Braunschweig, das dann auch gleichzeitig das Endergebnis war und jetzt eben das 1 zu 1 in Magdeburg. Das waren nahezu Kopien. Also du hattest lange Sololäufe, einmal von Tempelmann, der dann glücklicherweise vor dem 16. noch mal in den Ball kommt und dann vollendet. Und jetzt eben Burcu, der auch in der eigenen Hälfte startet und bis zum 16. durchmarschieren kann. Das hätte fünf Spieler geben können, die ihn hätten stoppen können. Also das bedeutet, du hast auch eine fehlende Abgezocktheit in diesen beiden Fällen, die so wie das Messer durch die Butter fahren zu lassen, ist wirklich unverständlich. Da muss man auch mal in Foul ziehen und jetzt niemanden umhauen, aber einfach am Trikot ziehen oder sonst was, damit es an der Stelle dann halt ein taktisches Foul ist. Aber diese beiden Soli waren einfach ärgerlich, weil es in beiden Fällen die Niederlage eingeleitet hat. Und ja, das ist schon schwer zu verknusen, wenn es dann gar zu einfach geht.
Vielleicht nicht. Also sorry, sag gerne mal.
Ja, willst du aber den Vorwurf der Kaderplanung geben? Weil korrigiere ich gerne, wenn ich falsch liege. Aber ich glaube, ihr habt doch mit Riedel, Magliza und Vukotic eigentlich gar keine etatmäßigen Innenverteidiger mehr, oder? Und ich finde ja, dass Magliza und Vukotic jetzt keine Verteidiger sind, mit der man jetzt defensiv Höheres erreicht, vor allem wenn man sich die physischen Defizite anguckt und so. Und ich glaube, ich finde es persönlich fahrlässig, so mit nur drei Verteidigern zu planen.
Ja, also es gab sogar unser Lieberknecht, als man die Saison gestartet ist, das plante man mit einer Dreier-, Fünferkette, das heißt dann nominell eher Dreienverteidiger. Damals gab es noch Klaus Gersula. Andy Müller hat jetzt auch die Innenposition in einer Dreierkette übernommen, also nicht mehr im defensiven Mittelfeld gegen Magdeburg, sondern weiter hinten angesiedelt. Das hat insofern ganz gut geklappt, weil man lange Zeit außen doppeln konnte und damit Magdeburg gar nicht so richtig ins letzte Drittel kommen ließ. Aber wir haben auch noch jemanden wie Christoph Zimmermann, der leider dauerverletzt ist und gar nicht mehr eine Rolle spielt, der wohl, liest man mit auslaufendem Vertrag wohl auch nicht mehr weiter bei den Lilien dann sein wird im neuen Jahr oder er ist jetzt auch nicht mehr der Allerjüngste, keine Ahnung, was da seine persönlichen Ziele sind. Aber was will ich sagen, also wir hatten schon zu Saisonbeginn die berechtigte Hoffnung mit Yasula Zimmermann und eventuell auch mit einem Andy Müller in der Innenverteidigung auflaufen zu können. Gleichwohl ist Andy Müller für mich kein per se Innenverteidiger, schon allein von der Körpergröße nicht. Und jetzt haben wir in der Winterpause noch Dreskovic geholt, ein Montenegriner, der in Ungarn gespielt hat, da nach den Informationen, die mir vorliegen, durchaus eine gute Rolle spielte im Ranking der Innenverteidiger liegweit. Aber Ungarn-Asteliga ist jetzt sicherlich noch mal ein anderer Schnack. Und er hat zum Beispiel jetzt auch nicht den Vortritt vor Magliza erhalten in Magdeburg. Und Magliza ist ein Linksfuß. Also der hat auch mir gegenüber in Interviews schon gesagt, wenn er die Möglichkeit hat, mit links oder rechts zu spielen, dann macht das mit links. Und jetzt war halt der rechte Innenverteidiger in der Dreierkette auch nicht so geschickt. Und er ist natürlich jetzt auch nicht in der Spielpraxis. Also hat man ihm vielleicht auch nicht so gut getan, in so ein Spiel dann reingeworfen zu werden. Gleichwohl erste Halbzeit hätte ich ihm da keine Schuld zugesprochen an irgendwas. Aber zweite Halbzeit, wenn drei Tore über deine Seite fallen, im Verbunden mit Lopez, schwierig. Also um deine Frage aufzugreifen, ich glaube, kadertechnisch war das jetzt nicht fahrlässig, was man gemacht hat, aber es hat sich durch gewisse Ausfälle dann doch ein bisschen zugespitzt. Und da man aber auf Viererkette wiederum umgestellt hat, glaube ich, ist ohne jetzt Dreskovic Leistungen kennen zu können, doch zumindest so, dass ich jetzt nicht da die sportliche Verantwortlichkeit anzählen würde. Also ich denke, da sehe ich jetzt nicht den wirklich wunden Punkt. Man hatte natürlich vor der Saison noch Paul Will geholt für die sechste Position im Tandem mit Klefisch wäre das glaube ich sehr vielversprechend gewesen. Klefisch eher der Dauerläufer und eher robustere Spieler, der dazwischen fegt und Paul Will als sehr feiner Spielmacher von hinten raus. Das hätte für mich gut funktionieren können, aber gleichwohl kannst du dich natürlich nie von Verletzungen freisprechen. Nur wahrscheinlich denkt ein Kaderplaner oder auch ein Trainer eher so von seiner ersten Elf her, dass er sagt, okay um die herum versuche ich was aufzubauen und dann habe ich noch ein paar, die hinten dran als Backup sind, wie Andi Müller, wie Papella, aber die mussten jetzt leider, was heißt leider, die durften sich jetzt beweisen, die sind im Endeffekt die Doppel-Sechs-Zeit seit längerem und machen es jetzt nicht per se schlecht, aber haben jetzt auch nicht vielleicht diese Körperlichkeit wie ein Kläfisch oder andere. Also eher kleinere, durchaus auch spielstärkere Sechser, aber keine, die jetzt wahrscheinlich Ligaspitze sind.
Ich musste ein bisschen lachen, als du eben meintest, auch einfach mal im Mittelfeld das Foul ziehen, vielleicht dann nicht direkt für Fabian Nürnberger.
Ja, total total dämlich. Also da gab es auch genug Lilen-Fans, mit denen ich mich unterhalten hat, für alle, die es nicht vor Augen haben. Also wir gegen Elbersbergen, absolutes Frustfoul in Verbindung mit Körperverletzung an Elias Baum. Also das war wirklich fast schon mit Ansage, weil nach dem 3 zu 0 kam die Mannschaft zusammen, um sich mal auf dem Feld zu sammeln und Nürnberger ist nur ein Stück weit hingegangen, dann wird er umgedreht, also hat sich da gar nicht in den Kreis integriert und wenig später wird er von Baum überlaufen oder ausgetribbelt und er haut ihm ohne Chance auf den Ball mit voller Wucht gegen das Knie. Also rot mit Ansage und dann auch noch Handgreiflichkeit anzunehmen, sag ich mal und auszuteilen. Doppeldeemlich 8 Spiele Spereger hab ich auch schon lang nicht mehr gehört. Gleichwohl 3 auf Bewährung, das heißt 2 Spiele dürfte er noch fehlen, dann ist er wieder da. Ja, also bei manchen Lidenfans hat er eher so ein bisschen den Arroganzfaktor, der so ein bisschen jetzt als Nationalspieler für Bulgarien wohl auch da eine gewisse Arroganz ausstrahlt. Das kann ich jetzt gar nicht so sagen. Muss ich aus meiner Warte heraus berichten. Ich finde, er hat sich mit der Außenverteidigerposition besser angefreundet als zu Erstliga-Zeiten. Also er spielt die linke Außenbahn im Vierer-Verbund und hat das solide gespielt, finde ich. Er hat gleich wohl auch immer so ein paar Leichtsensaktionen dabei, bevorzugt den Ball hinterm Standbein rumlegen, um dann irgendwie anderswo aufzudrehen. Das geht oft genug auf, aber manchmal denke ich mir auch, lasst mir lieber den Move und spiel seriös. Aber ja, er fehlt uns jetzt an der Stelle auch. Wohingegen ist Bueno, der von Dortmund 2 auf der Drittlassigkeit kam, auch durchaus gutmacht. Also wir haben jetzt Spieler, die nicht die Bäume ausreißen, aber die jetzt auch kein absolutes Downgrade darstellen, finde ich.
Zwei Punkte an der Stelle, weil du eben einmal jetzt öfter schon die Thematik der Fans angesprochen hast. Wie ist da denn die Stimmung? Also ich habe schon ab und zu, ich glaube auch gerade noch dem Elversberg-Spiel, dann schon ein, zwei Mal so ein bisschen Pfiffe gehört. Aber wie ist denn generell die Stimmung so im Stadion oder beziehungsweise generell bei den Fans?
Ja, da kann ich das letzte Spiel in Erinnerung rufen. Das war eben das Heimspiel gegen Schalke und da war sofort von Anfang an die Bande zwischen Mannschaft und Fans gesucht und gefunden. Also es gab ein Transparent, es gab Aufmutterungsrufe, es gab die Mannschaft, die vor dem Spiel bewusst noch mal zu den Fans mehr gegangen ist, als es davor gepflegt hatten. Also da war schon der Wille da, gemeinsam an einem Strang zu ziehen und das hat natürlich mit den zwei schnellen Toren dann total gefruchtet. Also die Stimmung da war hervorragend, das war auch Sonnenschein, wie es am Böllentoren natürlich auch lietechnisch sehr gerne gesehen wird. Und dann gab es ja noch dieses Motto Shirt, Demokratiewählen auf dem Trikot, also dieses Sondershirt, was auch ein Großteil meines Erachtens der Fans skutiert hat, dass das so noch mal am Tag der Bundestagswahl auf der Brust getragen wurde. Also da war viel angerichtet und es war von Anfang an ein enges Band zu verspüren. Und etwas wäre klar, war natürlich ernüchternd, das so zu sehen, so hergespielt zu werden im eigenen Stadion. Da gab es vereinzelt Pfeffer, aber jetzt nichts, was irgendwie hätte ins Wanken bringen können. Und natürlich davon jetzt noch so spielen, wie in Magdeburg nicht jetzt die sozialen Medien aufrufen oder die Foren durchs Kollen, da kriegt man schlechte Laune garantiert. Aber ich erlebe so, dass schon jetzt die Wahrnehmung da ist, wir müssen nach hinten gucken, alles andere wäre fahrlässig und unruhig wird es noch nicht, aber man ist so eine Hab-Acht-Stellung. Also ich sag mal, wenn jetzt die nächsten Spiele auch in die Binsen gehen, dann wird es schon ungemütlicher. Und dann bin ich mal gespannt, was das dann für Konsequenzen hat, weil wie ich eingangs sagte, ich glaube, die Mannschaft ist selber gerade so ein bisschen am Struggeln, auch mental, um da wieder in die Spur zu kommen. So nach dem Motto, anfänglich erst mal ins Hintertreffen geraten, dann lief vieles wie von allein. Und jetzt weiß man wieder nicht so richtig, welchen Gang man einlegen muss. Und ich bin der Meinung, die Mannschaft ist gut genug, um sich da hinten raushalten zu können. Das hat sich oft genug gezeigt. Wenn allerdings der Kopf die Oberhand gewinnt, dann wäre ich mir gar nicht so sicher, dass da nicht doch wir bis zum Schluss zittern müssen. Aber im Moment ist die so eine gespannte Erwartungshaltung. Wo geht es denn jetzt wirklich hin? Was können wir erwarten? Aber noch nicht die größte Unruhe. Und ich glaube auch, dass Kofeld nicht hinterfragt wird. Hier in Darmstadt, das hatte ich damals auch gesagt, ist man es gewohnt, dass das Präsidium an dem Trainer festhält. Also entlassen wurde hier schon lange keiner mehr. Es wurden eher Trainer dann weggekauft oder man hat sich auf keine Vertragsverlängerung geeinigt. Sozusagen wie damals bei Kramotz. Also ich denke, da hat Kofeld schon dieses Umfeld hier, wo in aller Ruhe und Nüchternheit gearbeitet wird und nicht jetzt populistisch irgendwas vom Zaun gebrochen wird und dann in einer Entlassung mündet. Deshalb tut ihm das schon gut und er hat sich auch gleich dem Verein committed, weil ich glaube, das war das, was er gesucht hat. Ein ruhiges Umfeld, ein kleineres Umfeld, kein medial im Blickpunkt stehendes Umfeld. Hat auch gesagt, er zieht hierher mit seiner Familie, was ich mir schon so dachte, vielleicht dann auch etwas riskant, aber andererseits tut es ihm vielleicht auch gut, wenn er die Familie an seiner Seite weiß. Und deshalb würde ich es ihm schon wünschen, dass er hier dann auch die Früchte erntet, weil bei uns Lillienfans war es so wie auch landläufig. Man hat so sich gedacht, Kohfeldt, das ist ja eher so die letzte Patrone, sowohl für ihn als auch vielleicht für die Lillien mit einem missratenen Saisonstart. Aber er hat sich dann gleich mal gezeigt, was er im Stande ist zu bewirken. Und dann wurde ja auch immer landauf, landab diese Kohfeldtabelle aufgerufen. Darmstadt ja eher Aufstiegsaspirant, wenn sie nicht den schlechten Saisonstart gehabt hätten. Und jetzt wird es ihm wieder vor die Füße gelegt, guck dir mal jetzt die Kohfeldtabelle an. Aber er hat gleich wohl schon im November auf die Bremse getreten. Also medial war ihm das too much. Er hat gleich wohl gesagt, hier, mir wär's lieber, er würde so ein bisschen die Grautöne betrachten und nicht mal himmelhoch heraufzend und dann wieder zu Tode betrübt. Und er ist nicht derjenige, der alleine den Erfolg zu verantworten hat damals, sondern es war das Team in erster Linie und das Team hinter dem Team. Und er ist ein Teil dieses Teams hinter dem Team, aber nicht derjenige, der alleine dafür verantwortlich ist. Und der Staff hinter dem Team ist mittlerweile auch mit zehn Coaches bestückt, also schon sehr namhaft mit Athletiktrainer, mit Reha-Trainer oder sowas. Das heißt, da ist schon eine Menge Substanz da. Und er hat wirklich wahrscheinlich auch angesichts seiner eigenen Vita damals gesagt, halt mal den Ball flach. Und ich glaube, das kann man ihm auch zugute halten, dass er damals den Hype-Train nicht befeuert hat, sondern schon versucht hat, gegenzusteuern.
Ja, noch zwei letzte Anmerkungen bzw. eine Anmerkung. Und dann noch eine ganz kurze, abschließende Frage. Einmal, ich glaube, es ist gar nicht so schlecht, dass man jetzt gegen Karlsruhe und Köln spielt. Weil ich finde, man hat schon eben das Gefühl gehabt, wir haben eben drüber gesprochen, vielleicht ist es fast besser, gegen Vereine zu spielen, die selber auch ein bisschen mehr wissen, was sie mit dem Ball anfangen wollen. Also die Aussteiger machen das auch alle berechtigterweise so, aber einfach oder die da unten drin stehen. Und vielleicht liegt es ja da im Stadt fast. Also zum Beispiel das Spiel gegen Düsseldorf eben als als Anhaltspunkt zu nehmen, wo man ja zumindest das Unentschieden spielen konnte. Und gut, danach kommt ein Ulm. Also da ist dann halt schon klar, da sind halt drei Punkte alternativ los, weil einfach aufgrund der Tabellensituation und generell einfach wegen der Lage. Ich glaube, das ist relativ klar. Eine letzte Frage noch, weil wir jetzt ebenso viel über die ganzen Vereinsstrukturen bei Hannover geredet haben. Du hast gesagt, du bist sehr glücklich, dass du Fan eines EVs bist quasi oder Vereinen mit EV-Struktur. Wie sieht es denn einfach, ich weiß, ein bisschen gemein, aber einmal zusammengefasst vielleicht auch finanziell aus bei Darmstadt 98. Und gibt es da sonst auch, ich sag mal, Vereinsstruktur mäßig irgendwelche Probleme momentan?
Ja, da bin ich jetzt tatsächlich gar nicht so tief drin, weil es keine Anlässe gibt, sich damit zu beschäftigen, wie jetzt im Falle von Hannover. Genau, auch gut. Natürlich hat jeder, der das Böllnfalltor-Stadion von früher kannte und heute wieder da ist, sieht es mit eigenen Augen, hier ist was getan worden. Hier wurde viel in Infrastruktur investiert. Das will gleichwohl natürlich dann auch abgebaut werden, die Kosten, die da anfielen. Da hat das letzte Jahr Bundesliga sicherlich nicht schlecht getan. Und ich meine mich noch zu erinnern, dass es bei der Jahreshauptversammlung auch so ein Schad gab, dass man doch ganz gut aus der Bundesliga rausgegangen ist, weil man auch kaum Prämien zahlen musste. Also, insofern. Voll gut. Genau. Man hat wenig von Spielers Seite dafür getan, Gelder zusätzlich zu erlangen und damit den Verein abzuziehen. Ja, das war jetzt kleiner Side-Effekt. Also ich denke, man darf die Darmstädter wahrscheinlich als einen der gesünderen Vereine finanztechnisch betrachten. Und man hat hier auch nie sonderliche Hara-Kiri-Aktion gemacht. Also man hat jetzt auch schon länger keine Trainer mehr auf der Payroll, die keine Trainer sind. Da gab es noch eine Phase. Da hatten wir drei zeitgleich auf der Payroll, weil Thorsten Fringsten nach einem halben Jahr gesagt hat, ich mach mal zweieinhalb Jahre keinen neuen Job. Und dann ging er nach Mappen und war es dann wenige Monate später auch schon nicht mehr. Mit Lieberknechts hat man sich auf eine Vertragsauflösung geeinigt. Also insofern glaube ich, da droht uns jetzt wenig ungemacht. Man hat zwar sicherlich Gelder in die Hand genommen für Liedberg oder auch für Corridor, der auch eine feste Säule ist. Aber man hat auch wiederum Gelder eingenommen durch Clara und durch Melem-Verkäufe nach England. Da wurde auch gutes Geld gezahlt. Also alles in allem, ich glaube, finanziell müssen wir uns jetzt nicht so sehr Sorgen machen um die Lilien. Da ist alles im Fluss. Und wie gesagt, man wirtschaftet hier auch sehr mit Augenmaß nach wie vor, weil das Presidium, das jetzt in Amt und Würden ist, in großen Teilen immer noch auch schon zu Insolvenzzeiten an Bord war. Also da ist eine große Kontinuität. Da wird immer gerne gesagt, wir wissen, wo wir herkommen. Können viele Fans schon nicht mehr so hören, aber das ist dennoch gelebt. Also man hat schlechte Zeiten an eigenen Bleib verspürt und kann daraus jetzt immer noch seine Schlüsse ziehen. Und wir haben ein neues Stadion. Die Mannschaft ist jetzt soweit auch nicht außer Konkurrenz unterwegs, sondern entpuppt sich immer wieder als Leistung stark. Und ich denke jetzt finanziell soweiten meines Erachtens, ohne jetzt zu tief drin zu sein, doch durchaus einen Haken zu setzen. Und die nächsten Aufgaben hast du schon genannt. Also mit Teams, die spielen wollen, mit denen hat man sich in der Hinrunde sehr leicht getan oder konnte die gut bespielen. Gegen die Anderdogs hatte man Probleme. Also man hat in Regensburg verloren, man hat jetzt auch in Braunschweig verloren. Man hat auch in Regen gegen Ulm und Münster nur Unschienen gespielt. Also so ein Selbstläufer ist das nicht. Ich glaube, in Münster und in Ulm nicht zu verlieren in der Rückrunde wäre schon fast ein Teil Erfolg. Aber mal schauen, Karlsruhe und Köln hast du gesagt. Da bin ich sehr gespannt, ob es eher so.
Da könnt ihr auch gerne gewinnen gegen die.
Hätte ich nichts dagegen.
Ich werde euch auf jeden Fall die Daumen drücken gegen Karlsruhe und Köln. Das würde mich sehr freuen, wenn ihr da wieder zusieht.
Ich werde es weiterreichen.
Ja, ich bin gespannt, worüber wir reden, wenn ich hier in zwei Wochen wieder sitze und mal schauen, wie das wie das geklappt hat mit den Vorhersagen. Also das ist ja wirklich nicht alle zwei Wochen kannst du hier gefühlt. Sitze ich alle zwei Wochen und könnte alle Leute wieder direkt neu einladen, über mit denen ich noch vor drei, vier Wochen. Also weil es einfach immer, es ist einfach, es ist crazy. Ich weiß, ich wiederhole mich da und das wiederholen sich auch gefühlt immer alle Gästinnen. Aber es ist ja auch schön, dass wir uns bei sowas alle einig sind, dass diese Liga einfach auch unberechenbar ist und das ja, es macht halt auch am Ende, also für mich macht Spaß. Ich bin halt da emotional gar nicht mal so involviert, noch, haha. Aber deshalb, nein, es ist natürlich, ich kann ehrlich gesagt auch die ganzen Witze rund um den HSV nicht mehr hören und so und auch immer das dann immer so, ja hier viel Spaß mit Elvesberg und Paderborn, erste Bundesliga und so. Ich mein, ja, es ist halt auch irgendwann, muss man dann auch mal anerkennen, wenn andere Vereine gute Arbeit leisten. Lange bleiben sie da ja meistens, trotzdem nicht, das ist einfach so. Aber trotzdem ist das ja irgendwie kein böser Winde des Fußballgottes, sondern da haben dann vielleicht auch einige Vereine einfach geschlafen. So ungern man das vielleicht auch gerne mal hören möchte, aber das ist einfach so. Und damit muss man dann noch irgendwie klarkommen, weil es gibt ja meistens dann noch so 16 andere Vereine, die dieser Aufsteiger auch verhindern könnten, wenn sie wollen. Und ja, vielleicht werde ich da auch irgendwann langsam zu zynisch für, aber irgendwann kann ich diese, also habe ich das Gefühl, wir machen seit fünf Jahren die gleichen Witze und es ist immer nicht mehr lustig. Aber gut, wir hören jetzt auf mit Witzen, weil es jetzt schlussendlich lustig ist. Ich bedanke mich ganz, ganz herzlich bei dieser Runde. Vielen, vielen Dank an Max für dein Debüt im Rasenfunk. Du hast es ganz hervorragend gemacht, wie ich finde. Vielen Dank für all deine Ausführungen.
Vielen Dank.
Und natürlich auch großes Dankeschön an Matthias, der uns mal wieder Darmstadt 98 erklärt hat. Und auch da bestimmt uns noch eine Stunde oder anderthalb Stunden mehr was dazu erzählen könnte. Aber irgendwann müssen wir jetzt Schluss machen. Aber vielen Dank, Matthias, dass du auch da mit dabei warst.
Ganz lieben Dank.
Ja, und dann wie gesagt von mir auch ein herzliches Danke in die Runde fürs Zuhören. Wie gesagt, erinnert euch noch mal an die ganze Thematik rund um die Umstellung ab 19. März. Da bitte registrieren, in die Show notes gucken oder euch einfach nochmal den Anfang dieser Folge anzuhören, wenn ihr schon wieder vergessen habt, worum es da geht. Ihr werdet in den nächsten Wochen dazu noch informiert. Wir hören uns in zwei Wochen wieder. Macht's gut. Das war der Rasenfunk. Von Ihnen unterstützt.
Herzlichen Dank. Bei anderen sprießen die Gehälter, bei uns nur der Rasen.